I guess he wants to be seen as an
indispensable ally ryan of course
against terrorism yeah I think that's
fair President Putin wants to be heard
he wants to be heard specifically when
it comes to a solution for Syria he
thinks he can provide it he's got troops
on the ground many at the same time
friend wants to distract or deflect all
the attention that's been on Russia for
Ukraine because ultimately what he wants
is the sanctions to be dropped and for
Russia to longer be a pariah state
rights around a mr. Putin's appearance
basically is trying to restore a
relationship but that will try and seek
to reassure the West that they're more
friendly than they have been in the past
will Barack Obama bite into that you
look you know obviously he's going to be
very reluctant I think he feels like
many other European leaders for example
that he's been burned by President Putin
but the reality is that the preamble to
this meeting so jesse is going to listen
to him and maybe you know a lot of
people out there saying he has limited
options so I think he's going to give
President Putin a hearing and I think
he's going to be challenged to walk away
from the meeting without embracing any
of the ideas at least privately because
at the end of the day you know Putin's
got troops on the ground and could do
something in Syria and President Obama
doesn't have many options Ryan the story
in the u.s. I got to play over the
weekend was Liz sly's fabulous Syrian
effort in the Washington Post how will
mr. Assad view these two speeches I'm
fascinated by how he will take in what
occurs at the United Nations look if I'm
President Assad I'm listening to two
speeches this morning well I'm listening
to President Obama of course but during
the morning session i'm also listening
to the president of iran and the
president of russia because those are
the two countries that are going to go
to bat for me effectively right and the
two countries that actually have forces
on the ground with the ability to
support me and change the situation so
what he's going to what he's going to be
hoping for is that they're going to be
effective in convincing everybody that
Assad and supporting Assad is the way to
deal with islamics the Islamic state
Ryan do the Iranians change their
dialogue or their stance because while
they worry about Damascus in Syria
they're also worried about their deal
with the United States on nuclear arms
yeah I think the Iranians will be very
careful and maybe leave some of the
heavy lifting when it comes to Damascus
in Syria to to the Russians because at
the end of the day what President
rouhani but the Iranians want is to see
the sanctions removed to get the oil
companies in and get the economy back on
track so they're going to be very
mindful of that in their conversations
and speeches in New York how will
President Obama avoid the idea that the
u.s. might be piggybacking on Russia as
it did once in Afghanistan yeah that's a
good one that's a big concern I mean you
know if you looked in the lead-up to
this meeting the two sides have been
saying that the other one initiated it I
mean they they agreed to meet but ever
since then they've been arguing about
who actually called for the meeting look
I think that we're going to get a press
conference almost immediately after it
where the administration says yes we met
we heard President Putin out we have
these concerns let's see where this goes
forward I suspect that most of the big
conclusions from the meeting will be
kept very very quiet because they just
they don't trust him yet Ryan shoko
thank you so much in London